I'm so hyped right now everything has
changed if y'all ever seen trauma the
end of the Tron where everything light
up this is all in caps by the way this
is very important to know tipsy and on a
plane is my dress itself could have hit
me but it wasn't cuz I not unless I was
that tipsy I forgot I wrote it right
Carrie Amy Schumer ASAP Rocky Anna Anna
my daughter just sneezed into my yawning
mouth seemed really [ __ ] pleased with
herself joke's on her
she'll have to bury me someday that's a
funny [ __ ] who ever said this
who would say that I mean I would say
Sarah Silverman but she has another kid
who was Ryan Reynolds Wow times the
ultimate truth the real [ __ ] whose deep
whose profound was it a politician
Morgan Freeman seiren me Perry that's
really good
she could be doing fortune cookies or
something I often feel a strong
inclination to marry Barbra Streisand
everybody
I won my hair is going back to its
normal color tomorrow
Prairie movie that be trunk oh you have
distracted me from my creative process
what oh that could be Kanye West
tiny you're kidding it was guy yes yes
it was Kanye West's new app suspected me
from my creative process I like it